Justice Sandra Day O'Connor why a book
about the lazy B basically because my
brother and I grew up on the lazy B
ranch and it ended up being sold in the
late 1980s and it broke my heart
something that I thought would always be
part of me and part of our family and
always there for my children and
grandchildren and their children was
gone and there wasn't any other way to
preserve it I guess except to sit down
and see if we can write up some of those
memories and make it real when did you
start writing it
Oh about three years ago for a long time
it was so painful that the ranch was
gone that I couldn't let myself think
about it it would depress me if I did I
don't know if you're like that but if
there's a place that I've really loved
and cared about it
if it's gone I'm afraid to go back
because it might not look the same or be
the same and I want it the way I knew it
and remembered it and maybe this book
was the only way I could achieve that
where is it where is the ranch it's on
Arizona New Mexico border the ranch was
half in each state along the Gila River
to the south side of the Gila River and
to the top of the Pelham Co mountain
range
it's a high desert area rather arid and
sparse there are some oak trees and
mesquite trees on the higher elevations
and it's high desert it's about five
thousand feet high even on the flat part
but it's it has a fairly decent climate
rarely gets below freezing in the winter
it gets
fairly hot in the summer but not
unbearably so how long did you live on
that range well I lived on it from
childhood until I went away to school
and eventually got married my brother
who wrote it with me lived on it always
until it was sold and my father ran it
until his death lived on it and it was
started in 1880 by his father so it had
been in a family 113 years by the time
it was sold how big was it it was very
large it was some close to 300 square
miles that's a large area but of course
you have to realize that grass is very
sparse in that area it's not like having
that amount of land that is well watered
and that produces a lot of grass it had
very little grass how much of that the
actual landed your family owned did they
own all that no oh heavens no it was
primarily public land when my
grandfather started it in 1880 that area
was part of the New Mexico Territory it
was in the area acquired by the United
States and the Gadsden Purchase just
before the Civil War and that had
belonged to Mexico the Southern Pacific
Railroad wanted to put a line through
from New Orleans all the way to Los
Angeles and the best route went through
that area south of the Gila River and
Congress eventually approved the Gadsden
Purchase
mr. Gadsden had been sent down to
negotiate it and so in 1880 the land was
basically unoccupied except for the
railroad and if somebody wanted to
acquire livestock and
put out there and develop water then it
was possible to homestead a certain
amount of land around the water that was
developed and the rest of the land could
be basically just used and Arizona
became a state when and 1914 something
like that
and at that point coming in to the Union
the state was given a certain amount of
state land and the same with New Mexico
New Mexico had a certain amount of state
land eventually when it was no longer a
territory the federal government kept a
large amount of land in Arizona and New
Mexico and of course a great deal of the
land is owned by Indian tribes so the
land that is actually available in
Arizona and New Mexico anyway for
private ownership is less than 15
percent of the land overall and what
happened in time was that leases were
negotiated for the state land with the
state of Arizona and in New Mexico with
the state of New Mexico and the federal
lands were administered by the Bureau of
Land Management under the Department of
Interior and an elaborate system of
provisions for parceling out that
federal land evolved over time initially
with the passage of the Taylor grazing
act and that required sorting out who
got what in the days when my grandfather
went anyone could put cattle on and but
many people did so there might be joint
use of a lot of the land and after the
passage of the Taylor grazing act the
objective was to sort out who should be
using what part and not have multiple
use at least grazing rights going to
more than one person for a particular
acre of land you say in the book that
one of the things you remember most
about the ranch
is silence yes explain my earliest
recollection is absurd or the absence of
sound I don't know how many people who
live in urban areas today are even aware
of how much noise is going on around us
all the time all the time from vehicular
traffic or airplanes or the sounds of
heating and cooling systems working or
computer systems operating or telephones
ringing I mean there's just a lot of
sound or people talking in urban areas
and at the Lazy be there was not a bad
there were no we didn't have electricity
for years so there there were no motors
running and there was no vehicular
traffic to here now the sounds you did
here were the cattle perhaps walking or
mooing making sounds that cattle make or
occasionally birds at night the Coyotes
or the windmills we had to get our water
from deep underground and in order to
power the withdrawal of the water we
used windmills and when the wind came up
they would turn and they would creak and
you would hear all the sounds of the
machinery of the windmill going and the
wells at the ranch by the house were 800
feet deep and sakura's had to go all the
way down the 800 feet and as they moved
up and down you could hear them and so I
got used to that but now if the wind
wasn't blowing and the cattle weren't
making any noise there was no sound none
and it's almost a deafening silence when
was the last time you were on this ranch
well just before it was sold I haven't
been able to go back since it was what's
there now it's being ranched and
in the last few years it's been acquired
by apparently a very fine couple from
the state of Utah and they don't live
there full-time but they have full time
management and they're doing a good job
of preserving the structures there I'm
told now this is co-authored by your
brother H Alan day where is he today he
lives in Tucson now how long did he live
on the ranch until the keys were turned
over on the last day when it was sold
and I can't even imagine how hard it
must have been for Ellen to get in his
car and to drive out all those miles on
that dirt road and know that that was
his last journey out as a part owner and
his manager when you were living there
how many cattle on the did your father
own well you know I am that's a little
like asking how much money did he have
in the bank but you don't ask that of a
rancher you say that in the book and
ranchers don't answer that question
there were a lot of cattle and the
numbers of course were controlled by
eventually by the permit system from the
federal government because they would
evaluate the land and the conditions and
determine that you could have no more
than X number of cattle on a particular
part of the land why is that that cattle
ranchers don't like to admit how many
cattle they have well because cattle are
sold of course by the pound and you know
what kind of cattle they are and you
know how many there are and you know
precisely how much they're worth and so
that's how much money is available in
effect you were born in 1930 in El Paso
yes
y El Paso my parents were living at the
ranch my father had taken over
management when his father died in order
to try to settle the estate and he never
left and he ended up meeting and
marrying my mother who had the courage
to say all right yes let's go live on
the ranch
and it was very primitive in those days
for her and when she had her first child
me she wanted to go to a hospital her
parents by then we're living in El Paso
Texas so she chose to go to El Paso some
200 plus miles away for my birth and we
returned to the ranch as quickly as she
was able to travel what's your first
memory of the ranch how old were you I
don't even know my first memory is
sounds sounds of the windmill probably
coyotes at night the cattle what about
the characters oh the people at the
ranch living there was like living on an
island you might say we were away from
everything we had no neighbors close at
hand and there were my parents and the
Cowboys who helped run the ranch and in
those days
Cowboys tended to be single men they
seldom had a wife or family and a number
of the Cowboys at the Lazy be spent
their entire lives there they really
were part of our family part of the
working team supposed to start a Jim
Brister well Jim was one of those
Cowboys who spent most of his life at
the ranch he came there when he was
about 18 years old he was from Oklahoma
originally and he was a huge redhead
with massive shoulders strong fellow and
he had married a little woman who was
not five feet tall named May and they
said she wasn't more than 13 years old
when they got married and he had worked
as a
in the Wild West Show he learned to ride
horses early on and he was quite a quite
a skillful Rider and a fantastic Roper
he could just handle a rope like nobody
else and he worked in the Wild West
shows that were going around the country
and he and Mae would follow the Wild
West shows and that's what he did
and I think it must have been when
movies started silent films or something
people stopped going to the Wild West
shows and then Jim started working on
different ranches around the country and
typically he would ride the the wild
string of horses the the tough ones that
hadn't been broken and he would
basically come onto a ranch and he brake
the horses that needed breaking and get
him shaped up and then he might move on
to the next ranch after he worked on the
rough string and he came to the lazy be
that way he was still very young he and
May showed up and he went to work and he
never left
was it Jim Risch mister that you told
the story about that he gave himself a
root canal he did how do you do this he
was the toughest man I have ever seen in
my life and probably the most
coordinated man I've ever seen and he
could stand pain better than anyone I've
ever seen
during the years at the ranch you can't
ride horses all the time and not end up
having some broken bones because the
horse will fall or you get thrown or
something goes wrong and he had all
kinds of injuries but he never let it
stop him I don't think he ever missed a
day of work no matter whether it was
this collar bone broken or what and one
day came in and he said he had this heck
of a toothache he just couldn't stand it
anymore just couldn't stand it well we
didn't have Dennis within a hundred and
fifty miles of the lazy bee and he got a
piece of baling wire
you know hay that you'd beat the horses
was
tied with baling wire some kind of steel
wire and we take that off hay bales and
my father never threw anything away so
he always had some wraps of baling wire
around and and he got a pretty clean
recent piece of baling wire and heated
it up on the stove till it was red-hot
and he jabbed it in his tooth where the
root thing was brought he just put it in
there my brother was standing right
there and you could smell the burning
flesh and it was unbelievable and he
never went and he solved this problem I
mean I don't know how people can be that
tough
I really don't who is restless Rastus
was another of the wonderful cowboys
that lived his whole life at the lazy
bee and he had been born and lived in a
little town near Silver City New Mexico
I think his father probably was a miner
but his father died when Rastus was very
young about five and his mother
remarried his real name was were file
estrada his mother remarried and Rastus
as he was called didn't like his
stepfather at all and he ran away when
he was seven and he went down the
mountain from Silver City and ended up
somehow in Lordsburg New Mexico and he
asked around town asking if anybody
could use some help who said he'd like
to work on a ranch or something and
people in Lordsburg said well you gotta
ask that the lazy B they can probably
give you something to do and he hitched
a ride somehow out to the lazy B ranch
and sure enough they said yeah you can
do some chores if you want to stay here
for a while and he did and he never left
until he died in his late 70s but you
tell stories about him leaving the ranch
because he got mad once mad at your dad
mad at my father and what did
call your father da I guess that started
when my sister was born and my brother
and sister arrived about nine and ten
years after I did and my sister was
little and she was learning her letters
and how to spell and she learned that
daddy was spell da ddy so she started
calling him da which was short for the
spelling of daddy and it stuck
even the Cowboys started calling him da
what about your mom she also had
anything man mo short for mo th ER so
they were mo and da until they died
isn't it and you all call her yes we all
did even their friends it was funny so
da and Rastus what happened well they
were out one day on a roundup and if you
don't have Corrales you have to hold the
herd of cattle together by having people
on horseback surrounding them and
keeping them all in and preventing them
from running off and anytime you're
working the cattle
you're also sorting out ones that you
want to keep and ones that you want to
sell and ones that need to go here and
ones that need to go there and they were
in the process of trying to match a cow
with a calf and Rastus ran out a
particular calf that he said belonged to
a cow that had already been put out of
the herd to be sent somewhere and he
said that was the match and he ran the
calf out and after a while my father had
a conversation with him and said Rastus
that calf doesn't belong to that cow
why'd you run that one out that's
they're not a pair and Rastus said well
they are too well I know that calf and I
know that cow and of course they're a
pair and my father insisted that that
wasn't the case
and
just grew so angry that he went home
that evening and he packed up and he
went to Duncan and he said I'm through
I'm through
if you can't trust what I say around
here I'm finished with this outfit and
he didn't come back and we couldn't
believe it that he was gone and I think
a week went by and he didn't come back
and another week and we just couldn't
stand it because he was part of the
family so finally my father went into
Duncan to try to locate Rastus and he
asked around town and finally found him
and had a conversation with him and
persuaded him to come back and give the
Lazy be another try but my father never
challenged anything Resta said again I
can tell you that there's also an
interesting story about Erastus and your
father and a cult that your father ended
up killing when I mean not a cult but a
calf and and the problem of getting the
mother to know what this nurse nurse
except the camp yeah and how did that
what was that all about were you
involved in that yourself well I saw him
do it a lot of times Rastus was amazing
in his ability to work with the cattle
and we raised our cattle to look alike
to look exactly alike cow buyers wanted
uniform appearance and I tell you I
think Rastus knew every cow and every
calf on the place the thousands of them
he just wasn't wrong about them
and if a mother cow is nursing a calf a
calf is still dependent on the mother's
milk if something happens to the calf
the mother cow won't accept other calves
that aren't hers usually and yet her
udder will be badly swollen and in need
of milking
and she has enough milk to support
another calf but she won't accept one
normally I mean it's something about the
inherent nature of the cow and so there
were several occasions actually although
I think I mentioned only one in the book
when a particular calf would have been
killed probably by a coyote coyotes
would often take small calves and start
eating them from the back end forward
and kill them and it left the mother cow
without a calf and we had some dogie
calves at the corral the calves whose
mothers had been killed or died for some
reason and we'd try to raise the little
calves and you'd have to feed them milk
with a bottle if you didn't have a
another cow that would take them and
rest us went out and he took the skin
that was left from the dead calf that
the coyote had killed and he tied it
around one of the dogie calves
tied it on so that the mother cow would
smell the skin of her own dead calf and
accept it
cows have very poor eyes they have
terrible eyesight and the cows don't
recognize their calves by appearance
they identified him by Snell and so when
rest has succeeded in time the skin on
of the dead calf then the cow got used
to this new calf and gradually he can
take the old dead skin off and she
accepted the new calf but things like
that went on a lot wrasses call you tani
was that the one he did I guess when I
was very small and learning to speak I
tried to pronounce my own name and it
came out as tani instead of Sandra and
so he called me that picture on the
cover is how old
I'm not sure I suppose I was 9 or 10
years old what's the name of that -
Chico and Chico was a wonderful horse he
was one that came out of a string of
wild horses there were a lot of Mustangs
in the southwest in those days horses
that were wild and just roamed around
and Chico came out of one of those
strings he was a perfect little horse
but very small and that was ideal for a
child and he ended up being the gentlest
kindest most wonderful horse I've ever
known
he just was fabulous and he lived to be
a very old age he died in his mid-30s I
think which for a horse is pretty old
correct me if I'm wrong but there were
horses named swastika mm-hmm
hysterectomy yes and terrible names
where did they come well just whatever
some cowboy would think of my brother
really enjoyed working with young horses
and if he had a horse he liked he'd give
the horse a very nice name like candy or
hell no sir something pleasant but we
had another old-time cowboy who lived at
the ranch all his life named Claude and
Claude was a believer that it was very
dangerous to give a horse a good name
that something bad would go wrong if you
did and so over the years he persuaded
my brother that we ought to give the
horses some of these less pleasant
sounding names here's a picture of you
when you were 12 yes what was life like
for you at that age well life at that
age meant having to go away to school
and that was a very painful time for me
actually it's hard for ranch families
who have children because when it's time
for a child to go to school many
ranchers send their
wives into town to rent or buy a house
and to live with the children during the
school year and that means the husband
and wife are separated and my father and
mother were really deeply in love with
each other and they didn't want to be
separated they didn't want to do that
and so my mother's parents were living
in El Paso and my grandmother Wilkie in
El Paso was very young for a grandmother
she had married at age 16 herself she
was very young had plenty of energy and
she said she would just be delighted to
keep me in El Paso for school and so
that was the arrangement that was made
and I went away to school I would come
home at Christmas and over Easter break
and in the summers but other than that I
was staying in El Paso and that was all
right except I was homesick I really
loved the ranch and love being with my
parents and I didn't wanna be away so I
remember those years with considerable
pain and actually what was it like when
you found out that your mother had been
married before well I was very shocked
what year was that I don't remember I
was a student in El Paso and I remember
one of the children I knew saying I know
something about you know you don't yes I
do I know something about you and your
mother no II don't
what is it well your mother was married
before she had another husband and I
said oh that's not true I know you're
wrong and when I went home to my
grandmother's that evening I asked her
about it I said now somebody at school
told me that mo had been married before
that's not true
and my grandmother said well actually it
is she she had a brief marriage before
she went and married your father and I
guess that was something that in those
days
vorse wasn't encouraged and probably
looked down upon a little bit I don't
know anyway it had never been mentioned
to me and I was very shocked you talked
to your mama finally I did and she
couldn't believe that I had heard that
but she said well yes it's true now
that's that let's go on the picture in
the book of you when you were 16 years
old if I read it right you went to
Stanford that year I did yes and
graduated from law school by the time
they were what 20 I was Norm's close to
22 when I wanted to well I want to take
you to get out of Stanford well I
finished my major in three years but I
needed some additional credits to
account for the undergraduate degree and
I applied to the law school for early
admission at the law school and to my
great surprise they took me so my first
year of law school counted as credits
for my undergraduate degree and so then
I had two additional years of Law School
what were you like when you were 16
ignorant naive about what well about
what life for a woman lawyer might be
like for one thing it never occurred to
me that there weren't women lawyers out
there and that it might be hard to get a
job as a mom I never thought about that
you know I kept thinking when I read the
book that your life here at the Supreme
Court might be that your life on the
ranch might even be a metaphor for what
we have at the Supreme Court cuz you
were you and your mother we're
surrounded by all men right what did you
learn by being surrounded by all men
well I learned that women could do all
right and be accepted if they could do
the job I guess that's why assumed when
I went to law school but I wouldn't have
any trouble getting a job you tell us
that your mother took the LA Times at
home and she read The New Yorker and you
had conversation and your father read
all the time they bought books
constantly kept a library and when they
ran out of space they would sometimes
give some books to the local library
and they were both readers and they
loved to subscribe to magazines time and
Saturday Evening Post and the National
Geographic and so on and we only went to
town once a week and we get the mail and
get the groceries and when we come back
with the mail there'd be a big battle in
the family about who got which magazine
first because we were kind of starved
for news and we loved to read everything
we could put our hands on so there was a
big race for the mail to see who got
what first when did you have television
first
oh goodness it was probably after I was
out of college
we got elect we had an electric
generator by the time I was in college
and that ran on some kind of natural gas
and my father could start it up at night
and run it for a while at night and we'd
have lights in the evening but then the
REA the rural electrification Act had
been passed during the Franklin
Roosevelt administration and the whole
purpose of that was to try to bring
electricity to rural areas that didn't
have it and in those days there were
many rural areas in America that didn't
have electricity and while electricity
did come then to the Duncan Valley and
de verdun and to Lordsburg it did not
come out to the ranches and my father
made some arrangement with the local REA
that he would build the line put the
poles in in to their specifications and
string the wire to their specs if he
could get hooked up and when I was away
at Stanford I think we finally got
hooked up with the REA and that was very
helpful because at that point it was
possible then
to eventually put an electric pump down
in the wells and get our water pumped
out with that electric energy and my
mother could have a refrigerator in the
kitchen and run a vacuum cleaner and a
washing machine and all those things
that hadn't been easy to do how much
education did your father have he never
went to college he went to high school
in Pasadena his father and found someone
to manage the ranch eventually and the
family had moved to Pasadena Pasadena
what for in California and my father
went through high school in Pasadena and
he had wanted to go to Stanford and it
was at the time of World War one and two
things happen my father was drafted
briefly before the end of World War one
although he never saw military action
because it ended and his father died and
my father was sent out to the ranch to
try to keep the lid on things I'm sorry
how much education your mother my mother
had a degree from the University of
Arizona and she had taught school grade
school I think for a while in El Paso so
when did you give in that atmosphere at
that ranch and all the newspapers
magazines coming up when did you begin
to form your own views strong views
about life did you not till I went off
to Stanford I suppose I mean I read a
lot of things but I don't think that I
had a cohesive philosophy of life at
that point I was basically very
uneducated and I went to high school as
you know in El Paso and in those days it
wasn't fashionable to get good grades so
I did have good grades but I tried not
to have anybody know about it and I
don't think I learned much and when I
went off to Stanford I was really
astounded at the depth of knowledge of
my classmates and many of them were
really remarkably well educated compared
to me and I just thought I was very
deficient and I'm sure I was if I read
it right this year is the 50th
anniversary of your marriage to John
O'Connor yes that's right and you tell a
story in this book about that you know
I'm gonna ask you you tell a story of
this book about the first time that you
brought him to the ranch yes what
happened well it was funny John grew up
in San Francisco he was a city boy he
knew nothing about ranch life I mean
that it just he had never lived in the
country and I was a little concerned
about having him get along well with my
family since he knew so little about
ranch life and I didn't know whether
he'd be accepted by the Cowboys either I
didn't know if he could ride a horse
well or you know anything so we made a
trip out to the ranch and drove out to
the ranch and drove up one afternoon you
could see the dustcloud way off they
knew we were coming because you will see
the cart dust for five miles out and we
got up to the house and my mother of
course rushed out of the door to greet
us and be so happy to see us and to see
John and I said well where's da and she
said well he and the men are down in the
Krell branding some calves maybe you
better go down there and tell him hello
so after a while John and I walked down
to the corral and there was a lot of
activity down there they were branding
that day right at the headquarters and
had some cattle in the Krell's and there
was a lot of dust and swirling around
and bawling of the cattle they had a
branding fire in the middle of one of
the Krell's and
I knew that my father knew we were there
he had seen the car coming and he knew
we were there but he never looked over
and acknowledged us and then finally he
kind of reached up and touched the brim
of his hat
and that's kind of the universal sign
out in that part of the country that
yeah I know you're there
so finally he said come on over this
must be John and so he stuck out his
hand and of course it was the hand of a
working man it was tough you shook his
hand it was a little like shaking hands
with justice Byron white you know you'd
had a handshake and it was dirty because
he'd been branding and probably a lot of
blood all over it and no telling what
else and so he said glad to meet you
John and then my father went over to the
fence and he pulled out a piece of
baling wire and he straightened it out
and he put two or three strands together
and made what you know skewer about this
long and there was a bucket down near
where they were branding the caps where
the Cowboys who were castrating the bull
calves just through the testicles I mean
they just cut him off and throw them in
the bucket and my father reached down in
the bucket and he pulled a couple out
and he took his pocket knife out of his
pocket and trimmed him up a little bit
and if they were just a bloody dirty
mess down there and he stuck some on
this skewer that he'd made and he put it
in the branding fire and cooked the
things down in the branding fire for a
while and then after he thought they
were done he pulled a skewer out and
held it out to John here John try these
and I think John was pretty astonished I
would have been but he was great he
plucked him off the end of this baling
wire skewer and popped him in his mouth
and chewed him up and sort of swallowed
ardh and said oh very good mr. day
now was your father testing well of
course as a as your husband John
O'Connor had any mountain oysters since
that day oh we used to have more than
our share I'm afraid that was one of the
things that cattlemen sort of thought
were a delicacy and actually my mother
knew how to prepare them and cook them
and they weren't too bad you know when I
grew up
everything was deep-fried you deep-fried
the steak you could have a perfectly
good t-bone steak and any cowboy worth
his salt would want it chicken fried and
you fried the chicken too and fried the
bacon and fried the eggs and fried
everything and so you fried the mountain
oysters too dipped in a little milk and
egg and breadcrumbs and they weren't too
bad served with some cocktail sauce now
you have had three sons Brian Scott and
Jay yes how old are they and where are
they oh they're pretty old now they're
all American the youngest is about to
become 40 and the oldest of the middle
son live in the Phoenix area Scott and
Brian and our son Jay the youngest lives
in Palo Alto he met this standard well
Scott and Brian are both in real estate
related ventures and Jay is in the
dot-com world still hanging on now da
your father and mo your mother were here
when you were sworn in to this Court
they were in the court on the day I was
sworn in in September of 1981 did they
understand it did they know what you
were about to do oh of course they did
and what did they think about it well
they were thrilled as parents of course
would be and what it meant for them was
that the minute it was announced that I
was nominated everyone they had ever
known contacted them to tell them how
excited they were and to talk to my
parents and so here are these two who
had lived that life for so many years
that isolated ranch were in contact with
the world and reporters came out to the
ranch and wanted to talk to them and
take their photographs and the world
came to their door and it must have been
interesting for them really to have all
of that communication at that late stage
in their lives I know it was fun for
them and it was a great thrill when they
came back here and sat in that courtroom
how many years did they get to see you
in the court well I went on the court in
1981 my father died I think in 86 I
can't something like that and my mother
lived another five years which one are
you like the most your mother or your
father Oh
hard to say probably my father because a
curiosity about how things work his
nature was to want to know how
everything worked and he liked people he
liked people regardless of background or
wealth or status higher low if they were
interesting people to talk to he liked
to talk to them and I think I share some
of that actually he wanted to go to
Stanford and never had a chance and
probably that's why that was the only
University I wanted to go to I don't
know that that's the case but were often
influenced by things we don't understand
that's probably that there's a quote
from him in the book if you want
something done do it yourself he was a
strong believer in that he thought he
knew how to do things that Blasi be and
if he wanted it done right he would do
it himself who do you want to read this
book
first and foremost I will be happy that
family and friends and people who've
known about the life that we lived out
there will have a chance to see it and
people who have never experienced life
in isolation or in the southwest may be
able to read it and have some feeling of
how it looks how it smells how it sounds
how it feels I thought my upbringing was
perfectly normal at the time but of
course looking back I know that it
wasn't and it was a special way of life
and a way of life that is largely gone
these days you don't find those old
cowboys who spend a lifetime on a ranch
anymore
how did you and your brother Allen go
but done this book well first we had to
agree we were going to and I was worried
that I didn't know how we'd have the
time how I would have the time and I had
Alan sit down and try to put down on
paper things that he particularly
remembered and I tried to do the same
and we spent several days together about
three years ago in the summer up in a
little cabin we have out of Prescott
Arizona
and we just talked about the things that
we thought ought to be included and we
agreed that it needed to tell the
history of the ranch it needed to
describe it in ways that people could
experience it and we needed to talk
about her parents and the Cowboys and
the cattle and the horses and what goes
on but it's like what's ranch life all
about and probably end up trying to
describe what we think the future of
public lands ought to be and how it
ought to be
how did you get Random House to
by the book well I didn't we didn't have
an agent and I had talked to Jim and
Kate Lehrer Jim writes books all the
time and I asked them one time how in
the world can you be so busy and write
those books one right after another and
he said well I try to write at least two
pages every day of my life
and I said how can you do that he said
both I'm on an airplane I do it on the
airplane if I'm at home I do it there if
I'm at my office I do it there and he
said you do that anybody can squeeze out
time to do that and I took that to heart
and then I talked to Kate Kate has also
published two or three books and I said
well Kate Huth you used as an editor who
what do you do you recommend somebody
and she said yes there's this woman at
Random House that I think you would like
why'd you call her and I did and it was
Kate Medina and she came to visit me and
we talked about the possibilities and
frankly I wasn't sure that it would work
I wasn't sure that what emerged would be
of sufficient quality that I would be
proud of it I just didn't know what I
was getting into and Kate Medina was
very kind and very patient and I didn't
want an advance because if I didn't like
it I didn't want anything to do with it
I wanted to see it before I knew that I
wanted to go forward with this I mean if
you put your name on something you want
to think well no maybe it's okay and I
was very concerned about that but she
was lovely to work with and encouraging
and so we just plugged along over a
period of time and we chair things and
we thought along perfectly in terms of
we wanted to do and cover and we had
only one area of substantive
disagreement and that was about how we
should characterize our father Alan
never left the ranch I mean he went to
the University of Arizona and when he
married he came back to the ranch and
worked there and I think sometimes it's
very hard for a father and a son to work
together in the same business my father
thought that he knew how things ought to
be done and that his way was the right
way and my brother like many young
people sometimes thought he could see a
better way in a different way and that
didn't sit well with my father and so
they had clashes over that sometimes
serious ones
my father had spent his whole life
trying to get a uniform beautiful bunch
of Hereford cattle that were polled that
means that they're born without Oren's
he didn't like having to dehorn the
cattle and my brother thought that bar
zona cattle would be better and wanted
to make that change and can't you
imagine how hard that would be for the
two of them to work out and it was and
other areas of disagreement - so my
relations with my father were entirely
different we never clashed over things
because I wasn't working for him or
trying to run things at the end of the
acknowledgments you say and a few
instances names have been changed to
protect surviving relatives of those who
were mentioned can you give us an idea
where they were changed well I'd rather
not but there are a few descriptions of
people that aren't very flattering as
you might imagine and I didn't want to
use correct names and some instances how
much of a tour are you gonna do to
promote your book oh very little if any
and do you intend at any point to do an
autobiography where you go into matters
I mean you drop us off at the time you
get into politics there's nothing more
do you ever intend to do a second book
well actually I am working now on a book
but it's a book about substantive things
some of the history of this court a bit
about the writing of the Constitution
and the Bill of Rights and segments on
some of the justices who've served the
court in the past and just other
substantive areas I've been here this is
my 21st year now and I've had to give a
number of speeches through the years and
the best thing for a justice to talk
about probably is something historical
and I tended to do that and maybe it's
my naive Kay again but I think there may
be some things in there that might be of
interest and so I'm drawing on that
wealth of research and material to try
to put something together on a day to
day basis in this institution how often
do you find yourself doing something
because of what you did back there and
they were in the ranch days well I can't
put my finger on it I guess growing up
on a ranch
gives you a certain amount of
self-confidence in your ability to work
things out and not be afraid to tackle
something you learn out there very much
how you can't call somebody in to repair
anything you have to do it yourself so
maybe a little of that at least provided
me the sense that I could do this job at
all I don't think my experience was such
that would immediately suggest I could
I'd never been a federal court judge so
maybe I leaned a little bit on that
experience as a rancher girl you were a
private law practitioner out in Phoenix
yes you were in the state Senate their
majority leader at one point yes you
were a Superior Court judge yes an
assistant attorney general it wasn't a
judge and I was on the trial court bench
and then the Court of Appeals in here
for 21 years yes how what do you think
of this job oh it's such an interesting
job of course I think how privileged we
are to serve here and to have the most
interesting legal issues of our times
come to this Court
and to work with a group of colleagues
who are so dedicated and intelligent and
competent and everybody on this Court
wants to try to do a good job and they
worked hard at it it's really wonderful
you know when I was in the state Senate
like in any legislative body there are
times when somebody will say to you will
all support your bill if you'll support
me online I think you call that vote
trading there isn't any of that here at
this institution and that's just
wonderful it's a place where everybody
sincerely tries to do the best job he or
she can with the issue before them and
give it their best shot and you're not
trading for anybody else's view by the
way your sister and did not participate
in that that's your only other sibling
why not right well three is harder than
two and two was harder than one isn't it
but it was very important that Ellen do
it because unlike my sister and me he
had lived there the whole time
uninterrupted and he had all that
institutional memory that was so crucial
he's nine years younger than you how
much
well I think he's Tannen she's nine
they were closer so she's in the middle
and what is he doing today
she's the older he's the yeah he it was
um I was first then my sister then my
brother and where is Alan today he says
Alan lives in Tucson and so does my
sister and my sister served in the state
Senate for eight or nine years until she
was term limited out the very place
where I had served before her and she's
now a County Supervisor for Pima County
for Tucson ease so she also has had a
life in politics as it were only a
couple of minutes left there is a there
are a couple of images in the book one
of them is if I get if I read it right
of you and your father or your father
and mothers seeing the atomic bomb test
don't like weather and I did we were
rounding up cattle on the very date that
the first atomic bomb exploded over New
Mexico and we've gotten up about 3:00
a.m. you know how you do for a roundup
and we were in the kitchen we'd had some
coffee and some breakfast in the kitchen
the kitchen window look north and I was
rinsing off the dishes at the sink
and it must have been about I don't know
four a.m. something like that and we saw
in the north and a little bit east this
unbelievable explosion on the horizon
and this huge cloud go up and my father
came over and we looked at it we
couldn't figure it out and I said what
is that it was more years and he said
well I don't know he said maybe it was
some munitions dump that went up
something like that and it wasn't until
sometime later when it became public
knowledge that the first atomic bomb
bomb had been exploded of it
los alamos this is the cover of the book
Sandra Day O'Connor and her brother H
Alan day and the book is called lazy B
thank you very much